all right
um i'm going to get started this is
lecture 22 on uh 1413 on happiness and
mental health okay so what are we going
to talk about
uh today happiness and subjective
well-being a little bit on mental health
um so you talk about rationality and
reveal preferences and what can we learn
from choices
and what does that tell us about
happiness uh we also talk about some
futility and how do we measure utility
um in particular how do we measure
happiness and is that a good or bad idea
um and then at the very end we'll have a
hopefully a llama
or which will uh at least improve my
happiness uh
hopefully yours too i've had some uh
trouble
uh communicating by email with the llama
goat
uh and their sort of keepers um
so i'm not exactly sure when they're
gonna show up so they're scheduled
um the problem is like so they have like
only different certain time slots
the the only time slot that was
available was at 2 30
so i asked them to show up earlier on uh
so 220 or
or so i hope uh that's actually gonna
happen
uh but i haven't heard back so i'm not
exactly i'm sure so it might have to be
like 2 30 i hope you don't have to
to to run uh there was also some
confusion about like which zoom room the
llama should go into and hopefully they
find our room
um uh even though they don't have an mit
id
uh so anyway that's that uh and then on
monday um we're gonna talk about policy
with behavioral agents which is very
much the
the idea that well now if people are
potentially making mistakes or have
uh certain biases and we might sort of
think that we know about it then perhaps
you can do policies to improve their um
behaviors
and uh in some cases that's
straightforward if you sort of think you
know people have
uh biased beliefs such as wrong
information based on which they make
information
then you might say well let's sort of
just improve their information and then
they make better choices
in other situations it's much trickier
because hey you know people might have
certain preferences that are not stable
over time and so then it's very
tricky to figure out what is even the
objective function that we should
maximize
um uh it might be tricky because
who knows what we know versus what
people know
so who knows that the government or
anybody else knows actually better
uh what other what's good for other
people and so in some sense if you want
to intervene
you better be reasonably confident that
like what you're doing
uh is actually well-founded and you know
better on what's good for people than
they know
themselves and that gets you in tricky
situations
because potentially if you sort of get
wrong or people if you just
misunderstand people's preferences or
their voices or behaviors
then you might intervene and make things
actually
uh because you just misunderstood like
to do
okay so uh what is rationality
in uh our classical um economics how do
we thoughts right
so broadly we think that beliefs
preferences and actions are rational if
they are
uh mutually consistent what do we
mean by that well we mean by that that
we see certain
behavior certain actions we can measure
people's beliefs in certain ways and
then we essentially can sort of find
preferences that can rationalize these
actions
and so that's a very sort of hot
definition and sort of without that kind
of definition we can essentially
say it's possible to be a rational
cocaine addict it's
possible to rationally commit suicide
it's possible to rationally marry
somebody
who whom you met six hours ago it's also
possible to be a rational violent
defender if there's certain preferences
that people have you can sort of write
down some preferences that
rationalize all of those things and so
the fact that
uh in mainstream economics are very much
the main
assumption so the researchers jobs is to
identify
this that are consistent with observed
human behavior
right so you see people being wise then
the question is like
what are practices that um
that behavior now what's the idea we
talked about this already before so
actors make choices
economists observe their choices and
then
generate these choices uh if
um actor were perfectly right right the
content to sort of give these imputed
preferences normative meaning
that's essentially if i know your
preferences that
that's what you should be uh doing isn't
like if you prefer
b i should be helping you to do that
that would be a good thing
for you now
just give you an example of like what
this sort of could let you potentially
sort of astray you're like where you
you might sort of argue well is that
really sort of rational versus not
for example uh jake jack who prefers
taking cocaine
over quitting jacks um have lots of
speeches about wanting to quit but in a
way as you can actually act on it that's
just
cheap talk um jack might in fact be if
you were clean i
bet it getting clean is too costly
because their withdrawal costs
um jack probably didn't to be on an
untried cocaine
but this battle was officially unlikely
that his early experiments would
make sense so finally a sort of cocaine
should be legalized unless it generates
externalities that's essentially that
will make choices
um they make uh if jack started taking
that must have been that like he
hurt uh we're not taking cocaine even
though there's a chance that
it really addicted and really be
miserable now
and now even if he uh keeps taking
cocaine
and it's a quit well if he doesn't do it
well then it must be a rational choice
for him to to uh
uh not because it must be that the
withdrawal costs are really high
now we talked a little bit about this uh
theory of rational
addiction much about becker and murphy
we talked about already
that you know there's present bias there
are
factors involved including biased
beliefs that might not be the case
important to sort of understand that
like traditional economic links until
very recently would sort of say
definitely um rational thing to do um
here in fact no good reason um
to to to make
certain or any drugs illegal unlocks
analogies right so externalities would
be like if jack causes like behavior
that's bad for others
then we shouldn't let him do that
because you know other people are harmed
and he might not internalize
the bodies but unless that's the case um
we should
intervene in any ways
but so now you might sort of say but but
but you know
what are we talking about in all of the
thought like how is that sort of
consistent with what we talked about
before
and at the key of that question is the
question of do people act in their best
interest and so um what we sort of
essentially assume
often is that there's sort of a rational
relationship between people's choices
what they actually do
and sort of the hedonic consequences of
those choices which is sort of true
well-being and so what we assume is
essentially that
you make certain choices that maximize
your well-being essentially what you
learned in like 1401 or 1403 is
essentially
utility maximization and that's at the
heart of like uh sort of the rationale
the
assumptions so economists then tend to
believe that most of the time people act
at least approximately in their best
interest
um now um as we talked about already and
this is sort of the
our previous lecture about misfit and
wilson um
telling more than we can know we should
be actually quite skeptical about the
fact that people actually know what
they're doing and why they're doing it
because you
know as i showed you last time in some
sense people often seem to have like
essentially
a clue of why they do what they do so it
seems like a bit of an odd assumption to
sort of say well
people are maximizing what's best
for them so now how can we check whether
this assumption is appropriate what
would you do so i'm telling you here's
certain behaviors how can we actually
check whether this assumption is an
appropriate one
uh lauren we could check kind of like
their well-being
after um they make these decisions and
if they're better
or worse off yeah we have to sort of
like somehow
figure out some situations where we can
track people's well-being
um ideally we would have sort of some
sort of experiment
uh you know there's group a b and then
group a i want
you to let them choose and then in the
other groups we or maybe there's
a group c in some group we essentially
tell people
you should be doing a uh doing one thing
and another group we say you should do
another thing and then there's another
group where we have people essentially
choose and then you can look at like
track people's well-being
and then we could sort of figure out is
the group that gets to choose actually
doing better than maybe some groups so
we actually just tell them
what to do if in some ways or the
[Music]
if i can essentially manipulate you into
making very drastically different
choices by changing like small things
that really arguably should be
irrelevant for your choice
like for example the social security
number like for example
if i could manipulate you with like
anchoring you with your social security
number and then say
would you like to purchase this item for
ten dollars yes or no
and that affects your choice well then
presumably that's a clue in some ways
that like
that something is not going right and so
you're you're not necessarily optimizing
because precisely because
the social security number really should
be entirely irrelevant arguably
some forms of who we talked about like
preference reversal or some form of like
demand from commitment or like
if that's the case it seems to be that
then there's self-control problems
involved or like biased beliefs in
various ways that we all talked about
which should have seems then to say well
you keep saying you want one thing you
keep even like spending money on like
say healthy eating but then like you
never uh
the food all goes bad in your fridge and
you keep eating like donuts
that seems to be something that's not
quite you don't seem to be maximizing uh
your utility but in general it would be
great if you could measure behavior and
then the addonic consequences of those
behaviors people's well-being
and if you can then could say well
option a or option b is better
for people in general or specifically
when you ask them to choose they can
sort of figure out what's best
for them notice that you need to know
sort of become a factual here
you can't like if i see you doing one
thing and then track your well-being
that doesn't it's not enough because you
know i don't know the kind of actual
whether you would be happy otherwise if
you were not to choose that
okay so so um a great idea
um so now how do we actually do that so
uh it's useful to have some terminology
here
um uh uh that in particular then
mccanniman
and others have introduced it and kind
of one remember this is from
tourist bin first skin condiment the
nobel prize winner um
who worked a lot on uh uh lots of
version prospect theory that we talked
about
the economy and also has quite a bit of
work on well-being and happiness
and so on so and he introduced this very
useful technology terminology which is
they call like
uh decision utility and experience
utility so now what's decision utility
so economists tend to use the word
utility or utility function
to describe the preferences that
rationalize observed choices right
that's essentially if you took 1401 1423
etc
people talk about the utility function
essentially it's the function
that you write down that sort of maps
your
um choices into well-being
and the function that you maximize or by
maximizing essentially say
well given this utility function um
given your behavior it must be sort of
this utility function is that or that
utility function allows me to
rationalize what you're doing
and that allows me then sort of to
explain where you choose apple silver
bananas
and um so kind of one calls these
revealed preferences this decision
utility
that's essentially the preferences that
rationalize decisions when people make
choices
uh that's the utility that they perceive
or that they think they will perceive
or receive as a consequence of their
choices
that's essentially uh you might call it
like wanting or
um choosing so
concretely for an addict the decision
utility of drug consumption exceeds the
um decision utility of quitting so uh
if that person makes the decision of of
taking drugs um
it must be that uh their decision
utility is is higher when making those
choices
um uh uh uh they prefer one option over
the other
which again doesn't necessarily then
mean that like afterwards the experience
is actually better but when making the
choice of taking the dog they think
that's a better option
for them now uh in contrast hanuman also
talks about
experience utility which toxic which
sort of implies or talks about the
hedonic consequences of choices
uh he calls these hedonic experiences uh
experience utility that's essentially
the the preferences that coincide with
doing so while you actually sort of
experience the whole consequences of
your choice
what experience do you have a good
utility or what's your well-being during
that
that's actually going back a long time
ago if you look at sort of some of the
important economics or bentham and
others so if they thought that they talk
a lot about pleasure and pain
which is very much about the experience
people have in their life
as opposed to utility which is again the
construct that you have
at the time of um business um
how do we measure sort of these sadonic
experiences so well being
um and then so there's two questions i
guess one is how can we measure this
if i wanted to know what is your hedonic
experiences of this lecture right now
how would i do this uh like how do you
enjoy how much do you enjoy things and
then second
well i can sort of measure your
experience right now maybe this moment
maybe this hour
but somehow i need to aggregate this
over time right i need to know
like you took class a versus class b
now i can measure you at different
points in time but somehow then i need
to sort of aggregate this overall
experience
and how people are doing that separate
questions let's start with the first
question
how do we measure people's um well-being
if you wanted to like learn about your
classmates uh experience in any
type of situations what would you do
what would you measure
one is you could ask them verbally like
uh how did you like activity a
how do you like b or like you feel now
right so this is like asking what people
want you could also just look at
um their facial features or they like
um and try to see how uh
how much they're smiling or or like
notice that that you need to sort of map
into some happiness as well
right in some sense i could be smiling
but be deeply unhappy
um and if you would sort of misinterpret
that so you'd have to sort of have some
function
from facial feature to sort of some
underlying well-being that's
somewhat grounded in some assumptions it
seems like reasonable to think that when
people are smiling they're happy and
when they're crying they're unhappy
but but i'm just sort of pointing out
that that's that
requires some underlying data to be able
to map those things one is
um this sort of physicological measures
such as heart rates
uh uh et cetera or and so there
um again i think some common sensical
stuff like if you're hardcore
if you're really afraid and like your
heart rate goes up presumably that's not
a good thing
but if you're really excited and your
heart rate goes up um i presume that's a
good thing so one has to sort of
add some assumptions or some structure
on sort of these measures and sometimes
you're sort of just
measuring them by themselves uh in
general it might
be misleading but with some structures
really one could sort of uh
use that well the other part is
measuring there's lots of neuroscience
and other
work on this measuring people's brain
and parts of the brain and seeing sort
of which parts light up
at which times um uh it could be another
option
of course again there you need to sort
of map that into something else
right so you need to be able to say
suppose i do something nice for you
or there's just something mean i can
then sort of
figure out which parts of the brain are
are um affected
and then i could sort of use that then
just sort of later now if i wanted to
figure out whether
suppose i could measure your uh brains
during lecture if i figured out earlier
which parts of the brain are associated
with happy versus unhappy things and now
i could see like what your brains are
doing during lecture i could then figure
out whether you're happy or unhappy
but notice you need to have some mapping
because otherwise uh it's hard to
interpret
um what's going on but of course people
have um
already worked a lot on that that kind
of mapping just to be clear so the
the real preference measures
are um let me just
show you what i have here but the real
preference measures are
useful for some things but in a way if
you wanted to sort of
measure whether revealed preferences
give you a good answer then of course
the real preference measure
uh uh is not helpful or but differently
like
you kind of want to check precisely like
if i get you suppose i
ask you like do you want lecture a or
lecture b um
and then you everybody says they want
lecture a or like whatever but a or good
b and everybody says they want good a
uh the econ assumption is by real
preference
they must be that a makes you happier
than b
but if i wanted to test is that actually
true
then i need to have your revealed
preference but then you also need to
know your counter factual in some sense
once i give you a good a and i give you
good b
how'd that make you and then i can sort
of so i need the measures that here have
here in the slides a version of that
sort of say okay i'm going to look at
your facial expression and see how happy
you look when i give you good a versus
could be
or look at your brain and see which
parts do the pleasure parts of your
brain
light up and if that's the case i'm
going to conclude that you're happier
with good a
versus good b or that's more so the case
for good a
and then i can look at like you reveal
preference is it really the case that
like you choose a
over b if the uh sort of experienced
utility sort of says
um a makes you happier than b does that
make sense
okay so what are the what are these uh
techniques
i think we covered most of there's the
observer ratings facial men
uh uh reports of mood pain pleasure
happiness and so on this is what
saying that uh uh
autonomic measures with you know is uh
the respiratory concealer your blood
pressure or like your sorry your pulse
and so on and so forth
sweat um there's vocal measures as well
which is like pitch loudness tone and
you can probably detect whether somebody
is angry you're excited and so on and
again you can sort of write some mapping
here you can look at people's brains
um there's also some responses to
emotion sensitive
tasks so if i ask you you know do you
want to uh
talk to a friend um or like do you want
us to do something nice and if the
answer is like no absolutely not
it could obviously be busy but like when
people are in a bad mood
they tend to sort of not want to do
things that arguably should make them
happy okay so we can sort of try to do
that
now why my decision utility and
experience utility differ that's of
course what we discussed in
in at length in the class class already
um there's sort of various uh different
um
explanations one is um we're going to
talk about this a little bit which is
inaccurate memories of past
experiences you might just misremember
um
your past experiences and based on that
you might have like sort of
poor forecasts of your future
preferences or sort of your
uh utility so this is essentially saying
like
people's um beliefs might be wrong in
various ways perhaps
because people's memories are um uh
tricking them in some ways
um people might also have like wrong
beliefs because they're gonna fail that
there's some failures
to to anticipate adaptation which is
very much like sort of projection bias
that we talked about already previously
i'm going to talk about this a little
bit more
um it could be things like emotions
which again are sort of in some ways
often like
um production bias which is about like
uh uh you know things like
people might be really angry or people
might be uh
um as hungry and well essentially
they're it's very hard for to make
certain choices
um failing to anticipate their anger or
their hunger or other sort of
uh impulses way over time
uh sort of other plenty of other reasons
but we talked about this
quite a lot and so you can think about a
lot of what we discussed in the course
about
disconnects between decision utility and
um
experience utility now
uh i mentioned this already a little bit
um sort of the the
third part in people's utility is what
um kahneman would call remember to tell
rv which essentially is to say
well when you think about like a past
experience
um you might not actually evaluate it
correctly
in the sense you might sort of as i said
you know you you i might
i i might look at your experience
utility using these kinds of features
and then i might ask you afterwards how
did you like certain experiences and
then i can sort of test
in a way are you how are you aggregating
or how appropriately are you aggregating
uh your experience utility when i just
asked you afterwards how did you like
certain
um experiences and one quite interesting
feature is
uh and people's remember the terminality
is what's called um excuse me uh
duration neglect people tend to remember
the quality
rather than the length of the experience
and it seems to be also what's called
the peak end
rule which essentially uh a sense that
retrospective elevations are
very much predicted by two things or an
average of
the peak effect of response recorded
during an
episode and the end value recorded just
before the termination of the episode
and how do i think about this well
mostly uh
uh i think about this is like being very
salient
so when you think about an asking about
like a semester or like a certain
lecture or a certain experience
that you had maybe a tv show or the like
when you
think about it and try to remember how
much you enjoy that experience
well what's most salient of course is
like is your latest experience right
that's what comes to mind like the last
thing you remember is like the last
thing you experienced
and um if the last episode of a tv show
was terrible
um that's what comes to mind and you
might say well the whole series was
really bad
even though maybe previously it was
quite good and then what
the other thing i guess that seems to be
really uh important is sort of the the
peak
um uh both positive and negative so if
something was really really great or
really really bad
people really really remember that as
opposed to like
um stuff in between and again i think
that's something that's just very
salient in people's minds
and then sort of then thinking about uh
these experiences that's what comes to
mind and in studies that
so what what are these studies doing
well these studies that that tend to
measure experience utility in certain
ways either through
just measuring people's um tracking
people's
well-being over time and then sort of
trying to predict
uh they remembered utility how did you
like that experience that's one version
another version is um
uh let me show you uh one second is um
where people do
certain tasks specifically and they
manipulate the experience
deliberately for example they're these
tasks which is called a cold presser
task which is
they ask people to put their hands in
the cold water and then vary kind of the
temperature or they vary uh the duration
and then essentially you can you can
then try to predict um
people's remember the child id and then
show things such as
duration neglect or they like and let me
sort of show you what that looks like
for example um this is a famous study by
um schreiber and conomon
they did a short trial which as you put
your hand into 14 degree
water
for 60 seconds which is very cold or a
long trial where you put it into
water for 60 seconds and then the
temperature rises to 15
degrees i think this is a celsius it's
not far night but anyway it's cold
um uh uh but so the point here is that
like putting your hand in the 14
uh for 60 seconds into 14 degree water
and then another 30 seconds into 15
degree water these are both
unpleasant experiences so if you did
each of these things in separation
people would say i went into 60
seconds of cold water i also don't like
30 seconds of 15 degree water these are
both unpleasant experiences
um so neither of them are actually
desirable and sort of if you ask people
do you give people uh this explanation
you want to experience
again people say hell no i really don't
like this and for both of these like in
separation
but once you put them together the 30
seconds of
15 degree water is more pleasant than
the 14 degree water
so when you do that people sort of say
they prefer the long trial
over um the shorts trial and the reason
being and what they remember
is like the last experience which was
not that painful
where things got better over time so
people's remembered utility is
is sort of violating any sort of like uh
uh
rules like what would you really think
in terms of nationality and
economics which is precisely because
they remember uh the end
rather than the overall duration so
essentially the utility does not
aggregate in the way we would think they
input because the experience at each
point in time is
negative there's difference there's a
pleasant studies uh for a colonoscopy
don't ask me about how they got ethical
approval for those things
but anyways uh uh studies could be where
um getting um extra um
um a minute uh where nothing bad happens
and essentially the treatment group has
better um experience and memories of
those kinds of
uh of the overall experience now that
sounds kind of like you're torturing
people but in fact
you think about it well if
in particular medical procedures that
are unpleasant
overall if we can help people
have better memories of those
experiences
maybe they will be a lot likely to come
back and get future treatments or delay
so in a way you might sort of say what
are these studies why are people
torturing people uh or whether
researchers torture people
uh uh i agree with that notion but in
fact
if you think about if you wanted to
design if you think people are under
um using certain medical procedures or
certain medical tests that you should be
doing
you would think of dentists if there's
some
people's overall memory or memory of
their overall experience better by sort
of having the end
of that experience slightly better than
the uh
uh then the previous parts
uh that i couldn't hope for in uh
sort of a behavior that's good for
people in terms of
health even though of course the last
minute of the actual
experience would not be pleasant nobody
wants to say like would you rather have
like
another minute of colonoscopy absolutely
not but like maybe the overall
experience
remember uh is in fact better than um if
not
so there's other types of experience
that shows this um
duration neglect and pete peak and
evaluations people have shown like
pleasant and unpleasant
uh
movies or contents of movies um they've
done these experiments with like
uh with sounds or noise of various
loudness and duration
there's also where essentially animals
are
are uh given unpleasant experiences and
then you look at like what
what these are different types of
experiences where like the animal can go
into like one direction or the other
or press on level versus another and
then bad stuff happens in both of them
and one of them is worse than the other
and then you can look at essentially do
animals of similarly uh
duration or other uh uh peak end
evaluations
of experiences and it seems to be very
much like a
um phenomenon that's also true for
for animals any questions on this
okay so then of course if that's the
case if people's
um if people remember
things differently that will lead to um
that will lead to violations of the
decision utility
maximizing the experience utility right
if you think about the experience
utility or like the overall experience
uh the utility overlaps experience
utility of a certain
choice that you make in this case i
guess the cold presser pass
think about this like sort of the
integral over like say in this case i
guess 90 seconds
in the first case it's 60 seconds plus
30 seconds uh
60 seconds feeling bad versus 30 seconds
of like
putting your hand out which is something
like a neutral experience
if you're sort of integrating that
presumably um the short trial will give
you like a higher
valuation of like higher better a more
positive sort of experience
overall right but then if you ask people
which one do you want because people
remember the long trial as being less
bad
uh people might sort of choose um the
long trial over the
short trial overall so then that leads
to essential violations of the decision
utility maximizing the experience
utility because essentially people
remember things
uh in a biased way
okay so then uh uh we talked about this
very briefly and so far we talked about
kind of
uh different ways imagine one specific
thing that people have done um a lot
is just asking people simply about um
their happiness and life satisfaction um
so
simply you ask people there's different
ways um um
are there sort of these types of latter
questions how satisfied are you with
your life as a whole these days
um there's also like affect questions
about like did you experience certain
emotions yesterday did you feel angry
did you feel happy did you feel sad and
so on
the latter question um is sort of a
mixture of some people
think of this as like life satisfaction
some people interpret it as happiness
others would sort of argue that it's
rather about social comparisons
so the latter question has noticed and
i'm going to show you the definition in
a second or in a bit
the latter definition is very much just
like on a a
on a ladder from one to ten how great
could your life be
um where are you in this ladder so it
has very much sort of this flavor of
some social comparison
which i you know is not quite ideal
because it
makes it like well on the ladder like
how far and low are you at the ladder it
makes it very salient that some people
are higher or lower than others
so some of the responses that you see in
those kinds of lateral questions
are about sort of happiness but they
potentially are also about
people comparing each other um to others
in society and so on which
which might not be necessarily the same
as like how happy are you uh right now
it could be now what's problematic about
these happiness questions or what's like
a
why are economists um skeptical or
what instances do we about
so just to be clear so some people would
argue like we should have like a world
happiness report and gdp
uh we should not maximize sort of gdp or
like uh
look at like gdp growth as like an
overall performance of society
instead we should measure subjective
well-being and that that's what we
should essentially maximize and policy
should be
the objective should be to to to
maximize that
so what's the pushback on that so so
part of that is
people and stuff that we talked already
about about
um you know uh remember utility or
people just might not know
what's what's good for them but what's
wrong with just asking people how happy
are you and like are people are just
going to tell you or like what's the
problem with that
so one problem broadly speaking is
when you look at different countries
different societies particularly for
example if you look at germans germans
tend to be pretty grumpy and not super
happy so when you ask a german how are
you doing the typical german would sort
of say okay
by which they mean actually pretty good
if you talk
alaska a typical american how are you
doing they say amazing they probably
mean like
pretty good um so uh when people
give you certain statements there's lots
of cultural and other sort of aspect
that made comparison
particularly across society is kind of
tricky
like you might think people in latin
america tend to report higher levels of
happiness
because that's sort of a cultural thing
which might be that they're actually
happy or it might be that that's
just the thing that you're supposed to
exhibit
while people in some other states uh
scandinavia germany etc might sort of be
in fact quite happy but like what they
report to you was just
some moderate uh level of enthusiasm uh
overall so one sort of
cultural uh comparison is quite hard um
uh
using those types of questions there's
lots of gallup surveys that people have
done
uh at large scales it's like the gallup
world
happiness whatever surveys there's like
huge amounts of data that are being
collected they're nationally
representative surveys and so on and so
forth
so that those data are available of
course there's questions and like
you know uh in some places it's much
harder to collect these than
others and so on and so forth and you
know some people don't reply to surveys
and so on and so forth for example
the elderly might be much less likely to
answer certain surveys or like some
people without phones or internet and so
on and so forth you might not be able to
reach them but in principle you can
solve all of those issues
but i think that's it just costly to use
it the reference dependence is a very
interesting issue
because in some ways you might say well
now your income but
then your reference point goes up
nothing happens to your reported
happiness but presumably you're happier
than before
so that went somewhere on the other hand
um utility might in fact be very much
reference dependent for example
um you might compare yourself to words
and then
inequality for example might be
extremely important for
people's happiness and sort of one of
the things that people argue is that
for example the gdp also including in
the us gdp in many places has gone up
quite a bit but happiness has not
increased
but often that's people argue that's
because in part
inequality also went up a lot and if
that inequality really makes people
deeply unhappy
well that is important and we should you
should incorporate that in some ways in
our considerations overall
but you see that causes tricky issues
because in one case
i'm doubling everybody's income and
presumably people should be happier
because their living standard goes up
um so presumably there even if happiness
doesn't go up presumably those living
standards have gone up and something is
going wrong if i don't see increased
happiness in terms of measurement
on the other hand there might be very
much real issues about
inequality is quite important and
reference dependent
matters for people's happiness and
well-being in the sense that like
what really might matter a lot is
relative income rather than absolute
income and we should
capture that in some uh meaningful way
um
uh oops sorry um in particular there's
lots of issues with like
depending on what i focus you on when i
ask certain questions i can get very
very different answers and one for
example
uh example of this is uh there's a
people that struck it out that looked at
the correlation between general
happiness and happiness with dating
and so what they did is very simple
thing they essentially just manipulated
the order of questions the first they
asked people about how happy are you in
general
um and then they ask people how happy
are you with your dating life
and a different sub sample they ask
people how happy are you with the date
of day in life and then ask people about
the general happiness and what that does
essentially it focuses people very much
about dating
as part of their life being important
and for their happiness
and similarly i think this is exactly
what maya was saying as well we just
asked
you about the lateral question versus
about two other questions about
uh depending on our phrase the question
i can get very different answers
um and what you're saying so that makes
it very tricky to figure out like which
question should we use how much weight
should we put on it
and even like things like the order of
questions
matter matters quite a bit which makes
economists very um nervous and so on and
that's why in part economists would
argue that we really should have a real
preference and choices
now on the other hand um i very much
think
the questions when you just ask people
and say i'm deeply unhappy
that has some content and so if there's
there's information there and so
then the question is well how do we how
do we weigh these considerations on the
one hand the survey instrument is
really just very fragile and we don't
measure very much on the other hand
um there's useful information here that
we should be incorporating
uh somehow so i just wanted to sort of
have you
that have that in mind and so let's now
look at some data that people have
collected
so what's a very nice source overall is
what's called the
um our world and data which uh
has lots of interesting graphs and
figures where you can look at happiness
and all sorts of things
uh data in the world and when you look
at life satisfaction around the
the globe this is very much the uh
latter question here which you see
exactly
uh uh as they were saying there's sort
of the
the latter from zero to ten and again
the latter question is very much
something hierarchical and makes it
makes inequality or relative comparisons
quite silly even if it only asks you
about like your worst
best possible life for yourself it does
have
the the feeling that really it's about
comparing yourself to others
but anyway that's very much used in many
uh cases often people call it life
satisfaction but even here they also
call it like happiness
overall this is from the world happiness
report and what you see is that
in general rich countries tend to be uh
report higher happiness scandinavian
countries in particular the u.s is like
reasonably happy
europe is quite happy um and then if you
go to like poorer countries in
particular in africa
they tend to be uh report a lot lower
happiness level
when you look at comparisons across
countries you see like a very
clear relationship rich countries
tend to be a lot report much higher
on life satisfaction uh compared to poor
countries that's a very clear
association that's true both across
countries
but also to within countries so what
this graph here shows you is
the average income in a country and then
these arrows show you
the gradient within the slope of the
arrows is the gradient within countries
and what you see is essentially
uh so this is like comparing people
within countries rich versus poor
countries
uh what is security sort of increase
income within a country by like a
thousand or something dollars how much
does
uh people's um happiness go up and what
you see is all of those countries have
like
uh almost all countries have like
increasing gradients which tells you
that both within and across countries
richer
people report higher life satisfactions
compared to poorer people similarly
um that's also true for mental health so
these are all questions about
subjective well-being how happy are you
overall asking the overall
population but if you try to look at
mental health
conditions in terms of particularly
depression and anxiety
so techniques so using
[Music]
clear definitions on uh psychiatric
disorders
for depression and anxiety and also for
other completions
you find that the poor in any given
location are more likely to suffer from
depression and or
anxiety interestingly the prevalence of
depression
uh um in fact also anxiety is higher in
rich countries
um there's some there's a lot of
questions about measurement problems
it's like it's
really measuring the same thing and so
on and so forth but it could also be
there's other factors involved in
particular issues such as inequality
and it could just be that really what's
really important is relative income as
opposed to absolute income
now we know also that anti-poverty
programs uh
improve mental health in various ways so
including things like
cash transfers and
other anti-poverty programs so this is
an overview of studies
this is essentially a recent
meta-analysis that we did for some
overview paper
of mine and what you see here is a
number of different interventions
both cash transfers and other
anti-poverty programs which
are more broader programs and what you
see here is the treatment effect
estimated in the different studies these
are
overall property anti-poverty programs
these are cash transfer programs
but overall essentially the overwhelming
um answer is that once you give people
cash or reduce their poverty
that improves their mental health as
measured by different
uh these are pwb means psychological
well-being indices
this is also like depression screening
scores and so on so by various measures
of people's mental health
giving people more money improves their
mental health so that's true at the
extreme in terms of like
really sort of mental illness depressive
um and anxiety disorders it's also true
for
other measures of psychological
well-being if you just give people a
cash they report
higher happiness in addition to what i
told you before
this being true in the cross section
now interestingly uh we also tend to
think that others are less happy than
they say they are so if you just ask
people
um how happy are other people in your
country in almost every country in the
world what you find is that people tend
to say
the fraction that people actually say
that they're very happy or rather happy
is is lower than they actually say they
are which is kind of an interesting
fact now um this is we talked about this
already a little bit how is life
satisfaction happiness related to life
events
it turns out when you look at different
life events and that's quite interesting
that
a lot of life events tend to affect
people's um
uh reported well-being or life
satisfaction
a lot for many events including stuff
like
widowhood or divorce or marriage and
other
sort of types of events or winning the
lottery these effects are very much
transitory which is to say like when
somebody when something really bad or
somebody happens their happiness goes
down a lot
but it tends to recover um quite a bit
this is what we talked about before
people are quite adaptive to many
changes and they adjust
quite well this is what people call the
psychological immune system
except for a few things including
unemployment and one potential reason is
that for example unemployment might also
cause
cause things like depression and once
you're really depressed that doesn't
really go back over
that easily that's true for women it's
also true for
men overall there's also some other
issues which you want to be careful with
and interpret some of this data which is
this is called like this evolution of
latent situations which is
when you look at um things like divorce
uh it tends to be that people
that um people is the worst you might
say well divorce makes them happier in
some ways
but really what seems to be or that that
or you would look at this and say
marriage makes people less happy
but really what seems to be the case
that you know people build up to like a
positive event and then that sort of
peaks uh positive or negatively
and then essentially go back goes back
to to what's before for example
unemployment
things tend to go worse even before
people become unemployed
um um uh so which seems to say there's
people tend to these underlying events
people tend to anticipate them already
um psychologically in some ways
now um this is what i was saying before
when you look at
uh comparisons over time um you get
sometimes these
situations were in particular in places
including china but also in the u.s
where real income has risen on a lot in
many places but yet
people's life satisfaction does not tend
to increase
why is that well that's in part i think
because of inequality going up
into the upward inequality staying the
same and relative income really being
important
could be other things going on for
example pollution is really bad for
people's health
mental health but also their happiness
and so on it could also just be that
people's
reference points adjust which is just to
make everybody twice as happy and now
everybody's the reference point goes up
even though their overall sort of
objective for being standards in terms
of like how much can they consume etc
has gone up
a lot now um
this is quite interesting data now on uh
ceiling effects
so people uh so there's some controversy
over this there was like some people
were arguing that
when you give people more money at some
point there's a ceiling in fact
it doesn't really make them happier
anymore now um when you look at this
graph here let me go back for a second
when you look at
um these graphs
here this oops sorry
when you look at this graph here it just
doesn't look at all like ceiling effects
looks like essentially
self-reported uh life satisfaction as
measured by these kinds of
latter question essentially is like
increasing and there seems to be no
ceiling or doesn't seem to be flattening
in any way you look at this one as well
it seems to be like
once you if you increase income by like
a thousand dollars
at any level it seems to be that like
the reported life satisfaction goes up
so again that doesn't look like they're
assuming effects
and that's true um as well if you look
at
these questions here this is a
done these service in the u.s when you
look at the lateral question which is
this one here when you look at annual
income in the u.s once you increase
people's income
their um mean ladder score which is here
on the
axis on the right tends to go up pretty
much like monotonically maybe it's a
little bit flattening but essentially it
goes up so people report
higher life satisfaction when they have
higher income
but when you look at people's affects
both things like positive affect which
is like happiness smiling enjoyment
not being blue being stress-free and so
long what you see is in particular this
is for the us
uh when you go from like something like
ten thousand to twenty thousand to forty
thousand dollars
per uh year of income uh there's a clear
increase over time so being poor is
really
like poor like um you know
in the u.s it's really really bad for
your
affect and for your reported
well-being overall but once you reach
something like 50 60 70 000 in the u.s
it seems to me that there's not no no
effect on positive effects feeling blue
stress free and so on
so one interpretation of that is that
if we take these affect questions as
more like a measure of
experience utility and happiness in any
given life
essentially having something like
seventy eighty thousand dollars per year
and you ask this is
granted this is like from 2009 so maybe
this number is not a little bit higher
uh but that number is sufficient to make
people sufficiently happy and beyond
that
um doubling lincoln will not do very
much unlike how much you smile every day
and how happy you are as measured with
those things
in contrast if i ask you the latter
question which again is very much about
comparison about how you feel yourself
compared to somebody else in society
uh going from hundred thousand between a
thousand will um
will make potentially um uh still quite
a big difference
any questions on on that
okay so then let me uh this is among the
most interesting
parts of this kinds of these kinds of
studies is the question about what in
fact so if not just income so you know
income essentially or overall if you're
rich
you're going to be happier compared to
if you're poor but again
um uh it seems to be like really if you
want to sort of not be
uh unhappy having income about 50 000
in the u.s is really important beyond
that it doesn't seem to do very much
um anymore but now what other things
matter quite a bit and this is a very
simple exercise
so what they did is um this is um that
he was supposed to read
um they looked at the gallup survey
questions from 40 or 450 000 americans
and what they did is for each of these
four measures of
of um psychological well-being which is
you know bcr positive affect not blue
stress free and the latter questions
um they were first just trying to
predict
uh what is the regression coefficient of
high income so if you just put the
sample in two and look at high income
versus low income
uh what is the regression coefficients
of that they find as a
interpreter that has causal effects
which of course is um
uh is a little uh problematic but you
can think of this as the question if
i wanted to try to predict how happy you
are what do i
need to know about you what are the what
are the factors that i need to know
about you if i wanted to predict how
happy you are in your life on an even 20
times you wanted to know
in 20 years from now are you going to be
happy or not what are the things that
you need to know about yourself and so
it turns out that high income is
predictive for this uncoefficient
that says if you have higher income
you're somewhat more likely to have
positive affect
less likely to to feel blue less likely
to be stressed and a lot more likely to
answer a higher qua give a higher answer
in the latter question so in some sense
higher income
is good and then what the table does is
it looks at
it normalizes high income to one and
then shows you other
characteristics and says okay um if i
knew another characteristic
about you i you religious versus not and
so on what is the relative
uh coefficient of that compared to a
high versus low income
okay so for example if you're old you're
um
uh positive coefficient means like
you're you're happier
or more likely to have positive affect
here and a negative the opposite
um i guess for positive affect here so
if you're old for example older people
at least in the us tend to report
higher um a positive affect
so that's good news for you on 20 30
years you'll be likely to be
to be happier um it turns out that
religious people for example
tend to be more more uh report more
positive affects compared to
non-religious people
uh and the magnitude of these effects is
pretty large
that is to say one point one six is sort
of to say
uh if you compare religious if i knew
about you are you religious versus not
that is as predictive as knowing about
you are you rich versus not are you in
the upper lower half of this income
distribution
so that's quite important in terms of
like trying to predict whether people
are happy
now what's particularly striking here is
uh
when you look at this here is alone uh a
smoker
uh and headache particularly um i
i wanna sort of emphasize the alone here
sort of social relationships or
people um being in relationships with
friends or and family
or with partners is extremely predictive
of people's um well-being this is what i
was talking about before when it came to
social preferences
sort of investing in social
relationships seems in one way is a way
of of course making other people happy
of the ignitions is good
but in a way about uh investing or
being nice to us and investing in social
relationships is very much an investment
in your
future lobbying
and the magnitudes here are like sort of
enormous now another way you could do
is uh so here you could say well
what should i do to make me happier um
in the future so one thing
you could do is just look at data so one
thing you can do is look at data
and while what is it what are these
predictor people happy
these are all correlations you want to
be careful
it's going to tell you something about
like if you want to be happy in 20 years
things you want to invest in
these numbers are probably like a pretty
good um
uh um your health seems to be like quite
a good idea
smoking for example um not so much
now another thing you could do is ask
people
um at the above and just about saying
um about what they should ever could
have done in their life
what do you think people said so this is
an australian nurse who recorded the
experience from palliative
as end-of-life experiences and asked
people about like
uh or she didn't necessarily ask but she
was just recording what people are
saying
what are the top five um regrets what
would you think they are
not spending enough time with family
wish to have worked less manila says
good enough so essentially what people
tend to say
is a combination of like they wish they
had done been more
social they had been i wish they had
expressed their feelings more that had
been more
uh true to themselves in some ways and
sort of not done things that others
wanted them to do but rather
spend more time with their friends and
family and so on now you want to be a
little bit careful with this this is
again sort of there's issues but
remember utilities also issues with like
if you are um alone at the end of your
life
you might be quite um unhappy because of
that be careful um
but i think we can actually learn quite
a bit about this so in some ways if you
think about sort of certain choices you
make in life
um understanding kind of um some of
these issues seem to be quite important
um uh overall and think about like what
should you maximize
it seems to me that maximizing sort of
income uh if that comes at the
uh uh at the cost of like not having
friends seems to be like not a good idea
um if you want to be happy
in the long run another thing that
people by the way here this is not in
here tend to
to emphasize but a lot is um having a
meaningful job or having work that they
believe in terms of uh
something meaningful as opposed to
maximizing um income
which you know um uh
seems quite important okay so then um
what kinds of things then could you do
to make yourself happier and have a few
things
um uh written down here so one thing
that i already said is invest in and
maintain social relationships
um small acts can make big differences
um
as we um talked about of letters of
gratitude random acts of kindness these
are very small things
um that you could do of course you could
do also like a really
really important things that matters
quite a lot how much you help your
friends how much you sort of invest in
um
in others again that's partially
reflective of just being pro-social and
being nice to others
but you can think of this as very much
as like ironically in some ways you can
think of this
also as like investing in your own
happiness in the future
uh choosing meaningful work over money
seems really important um
if you think about what you do with your
life there's so much talent at mit and i
um i sometimes wish you know that talent
would go more into more meaningful
things
or because of uh society or like making
society better overall as opposed to
like uh
um some perhaps potentially social
weight cities that pay you a lot
of money um that's in something sort of
potentially socially optimal in terms of
use mit's talents or mit students
talents for useful things in the world
but if you're just selfish and want to
make yourself happy in 20 years from now
it seems to me that just maximizing
income is just not what's going to get
you there so it seems to be like like
being rich is really uh
glamorous and exciting but in fact if
that comes at the cost of your health
and your friendships most likely or
happen or the cost of having a
meaningful job that you
actually believe in and i think is
useful that's not gonna make you happy
in the long run so
for those of you thinking about what
kind of work to pursue in the future
uh uh keep that in mind uh and then i
have two more things uh here on my list
which is
support to improve your mental health
and reduce social media usage
so what do i mean by that so
psychotherapies have very much been
shown
uh to be effective in reducing
depression anxiety and so on
yet people tend to not make use of those
services now why is that
there's sort of obvious reasons which is
stigma shame and so on there's also
potentially misperceptions
projection bias also like depression
itself for example could precisely
generate these kinds of beliefs
there could also be other behavioral
biases like other health conditions you
know people just don't like to see
doctors and so on
now another way to view this is to say
well you might think that psychotherapy
is really important for depression and
anxiety but psychotherapy could also be
viewed as like sort of a coach to make
you happiness think about this as like a
happiness coach
it might help you figure out your
objective function in life what really
makes you happy and how to pursue that
and that sort of regardless of
depression anxiety or any mental
disorders that's to say like
think about like sports in sports like
you get a coach to be a better tennis
player
or whatever like soccer or whatever you
sports you do that's very natural thing
to do people helped you to do better
now why not have a coach for many other
things in life including like how to be
happier on how to lead your life that
sort of makes you
uh satisfies you and i think that's
in some sense if you're maximizing your
wrong objective function which again
could be like you just
maximize money over certain other things
if the therapist help you
do that or help you correct that that
could be extremely valuable um
and helpful um uh and again that's sort
of in the absence of any sort of
uh serious mental illnesses that's just
for like the average person having
somebody to talk to to help you optimize
your life
uh and your mental well-being seems to
be extremely important
and worth trying um second about uh
social media so
uh this is a recent paper that's quite
intriguing and there's actually a couple
papers but let me just mention one
which is by al qaeda um that um randomly
uh randomizes paying students to stay
off facebook for
a month this was before the 2018
election which in election
uh which is in since it's perhaps
relevant in some ways
like the timing might matter um for some
of these results
but so what they find is that sort of
getting people to a you have to pay
students quite a lot to do this so
students have to pay them like 50
and otherwise you know they're not
willing to do this when you do that
people reduce their online activities
um they also you reduce their factual uh
news knowledge political polarization
and so on all kinds of things that you
might expect
then you see um increased subjective
well-being both happiness but also like
reduced depression so
students are happier uh uh and quite a
bit happier by
doing that moreover there seem to be
large persistent
uh reductions in post experiment phase
drop usage that is to say one to
experiment is over
lots of students who have been paid to
stay on facebook uh uh
tend to do that or to continue doing
that which very much sort of seems to
say that
uh it's a habit good perhaps there's
also some learning involved it's
like students learn that they're now
happier
overall now that always leads to the
question well why are people then on
facebook if it doesn't make them
happy and does it have to do with like
peer pressure does it have to do with
like habit formation does it have to do
with like um
self-control problems so that would have
to do with bias beliefs and so on
but overall in some ways i think the the
reason why i shoot this evidence is like
when you think about your life or things
that you do in your life you kind of
want to think about like
what are the things that you do in your
life what are the things that make you
happy uh
or or not and perhaps experimenting with
those kinds of things or just looking at
data from studies
um seems to be like a very reasonable
thing to do so it could well be that
social media makes you really happy and
connecting with your friends in
particular right now that's really you
think that's really helpful because you
know you can stay in touch
you like talk online and so on and so
forth and that's truly like i think
that's worth worth doing
so that could really be very beneficial
for your um
happiness overall but it might also be
that uh there's large
uh costs in that coming from perhaps
like social comparison
or like just seeing everybody happy on
facebook or whatever people post
selectively makes
it look like people are are way happier
than they actually are
and then that makes people feel bad
about themselves seeing others sort of
posed overall
but i think what i the reason why i
actually do this is i want you to think
about or be more conscious about
uh what are the things that do make you
in fact happier and try to
invest in those that seem to make
you happier overall so some of these
things you can obviously experiment with
for example you can obviously turn off
your facebook or instagram whatever um
very quickly and easily other things of
course the stuff that i showed you um
in the very long run um like you know
the uh
the kanaman data here
these kinds of data of course it's much
harder to experiment with that like it's
hard to just say i'm going to be
religious for a month and uh from now on
and then so see how you're happier
um but it is worse to think about kind
of what are the things that you're
really pursuing
and are these things going to be making
you happy not just right now and this is
just because you're doing some things
because your friends want it or like
some other influence that you have
as opposed to like what are the things
that you really want and what are the
things that are gonna make you happy
not just like uh this month or next
month but like five ten
twenty years um from now because a lot
of choices that you make
uh uh in the next couple or three years
uh will be very persistent in terms of
like depending on what jobs you choose
what kinds of um friendships you have
what kind of partners you have and so on
will be very much persistent for a long
time in terms of determining
um your long run happiness and so that's
a very useful thing to
think about um let me see
so what what do people think um um
and i guess um at some point hopefully
uh so if you look is monitoring the
llama situation i hope um
uh uh uh uh we'll see how that goes
hopefully that makes people happier
but um what what do people think is why
why are people on facebook if it doesn't
make them happy
so there could be essentially issues
with uh present bias or the like that
like any point in time
it's it's kind of the some temptations
of perhaps posting or the like and then
you know
uh that makes you happy in the very
short run but in the long run overall
then
that's not really um helping you uh
overall there's some so it's actually
some self-control problems in some
some some ways um in particular right
now and so to be clear the study
that was done here and i actually talked
to honda alcohol she was one of the
authors of the study
who would also tell me like look uh uh
if you did the study right now maybe you
would find the opposite
because you know now in fact facebook or
any other so social media helps people
stay in touch and there's some positive
benefits
and so what you're saying is well
presumably facebook was
uh you know uh uh um developed
early on or reason why it's successful
because it really helped people connect
to each other in some ways
and people thought there were some
benefits from that and that's
particularly true
if you're sort of not at the same place
uh physically and sort of
particularly right now then there are
these benefits
overall and then there's a question of
well what are the costs and benefits of
that
and you know
maybe people misperceive some of these
or or or the like
i'm trying to encourage you is to sort
of say well uh
there's ways to learn about this and
facebook is actually a very good example
uh where you could learn very easily
where you say let's turn it off for a
month and see what happens
you could also there's some other
activities where you say let's do more
sports so let's
get up early in the morning or sleep
more at night there's some things we're
like that are
quite easy to experiment with other
stuff as i said you know becoming
religious was just not as much
trickier to to experiment with or like
being healthy versus not in some sense
it's just a very much long one uh
uh uh the fact um but exactly as you
said people have
never actually experienced any of this
so how would you know
how you're going to be happier there's
also some
uh you know public goods issues or some
issues of um
externalities and some more if all of
you are on social media and you're not
you're kind of a bit of a
outsider and that sort of will make you
likely very um
or likely not increase your happiness
but it might well be
that like if everybody decides um uh
go off social media then everybody
sometimes then you don't rely
on social media to like go to parties or
whatever and so on
and so there might be also some
coordination issues potentially so
conditional on everybody being on
facebook around you you might want to be
on facebook or whatever other social
media
but if that's not the case when uh so it
could be for every single person
every single person could be happier if
everybody else were not on social media
but conditional that everybody is on
social media
that's not the case and sort of but what
i'm saying here is we tend to do the
same things over and over again as maya
was saying as well
but why don't we just experiment more um
often there's immediate cost
but perhaps like long-run benefits
there's default effects
of course and so on that keep us from
experimenting but if you think about it
if you could make yourself just a little
bit happier every day for like many many
years it seems to be worth experimenting
a lot
i would sort of very much encourage you
to go and try out new things in life
that
potentially make you happier um
assemblable and often has a nice uh
uh i hope this is still working the link
but has a very nice new york times
article that argues that
what do we do um um experiment more and
try to figure out what makes us
um happier uh any other thoughts on on
social media or facebook
okay so uh that's all i have
for for for now um
uh next time we're gonna talk about um
policy that's the last lecture
please do read um um uh uh
thaler and sunstein tells me the llama
is not not here yet neither into the
uh the the my
private room where the llama might be
otherwise uh also
here there's a wait i think the the
announce time is like 2 30 so that's in
four minutes
so if you have to run of course that's
fine otherwise i'm just going to
stick around and wait if you want to
talk about more i'd love to sort of know
more about why people are
experimenting more i also would love to
know more about
um how people think so so one thing i
was mentioning here is that well social
media might be better than the
detrimental effects
in particular coming from social
comparisons which is to say look
uh you see everybody on instagram looks
like they have a glamour glamorous life
and are happy all the time
you see that and that might make you
feel depressed which by the way that
might not
lead you to a bit of glamorous pictures
yourself it might reinforce the whole
issue overall
there surely are some downs actually but
there's also potential upsides of
connecting people online on
a project that i'm trying to work on
i think europosta anybody has some
things one could do right now online
to help people be more connected and
less lonely and more depressed and less
depressed